hey what's up youtube
this is april 1st yet all right looking
at the title of this video you're
probably thinking well i've heard a lot
about this little worm thing that we've
been
that's going around this conficker worm
it's gonna be bad
yeah anyway this worm is supposed to be
infecting other computers spreading by
usb ports by email attachments just like
any other virus would normally spread
but this virus is different because it's
landing dormant inside your computer and
it's not going to be activated and
actually wreak havoc on your pc and yes
only pcs until a certain date when it
decides to be activated now recording
this video on march 31st we all know
tomorrow is april 1st
april fool's day so there's tons of
rumors going around saying it's going to
be activated tomorrow april fool's day
your computer's going to die on april
fool's day
like why would someone do that why would
you
come on man there's people saying don't
go on the internet on april 1st don't
download anything april 1st don't plug
in a flash drive on april 1st because
your computer don't die but maybe i'm
the only one who's not skeptical because
i guess i'm not the only one who's
completely terrified of this virus i
mean
come on people have been telling people
it's going to disable your firewalls
it's going to be
intruding your computer and disabling
certain windows updates and patches and
stuff like that and your computer won't
be working at a hundred percent however
if you turn autorun off hopefully usb
devices won't be able to infect your
computer by automatically running
everything on that flash drive so if you
do have a
gig flash drive you don't want to be
plugging this in on auto play because a
lot of things could be on here that
could be putting your computer at risk
what i suggest is to turn off autoplay
which is basically if you go into
windows vista and go into your start
menu and type in auto play you can
actually um hit enter and disable auto
play on usb devices cds etc if you
really need a tutorial on that i can do
it but i mean
come on auto play so yeah microsoft is
advising all windows users to download
the latest patches which again are
available at the link in the description
but basically you're not going to know
if you're infected yet unless you turn
on your computer on april 1st and find
that things aren't working properly
microsoft says it's already infected
more than 20 million pcs just pcs
well what we've heard and i've put the
link in the description of this video
i've
dang it yeah i never know where the
description box is you know what the
description is i put the link in the
description as
i did it again
i put the link in the description you
know what the description is um about a
whole bunch of information about this
virus and i'll put it up now it's just
basically talking about how it can it
can access your computer and it's it's
not actually active yet but it's dormant
laying in your computer waiting to be
activated man i hate april fool's day
anyway oh yeah and one last thing
microsoft is offering 250 000 to anyone
who can give any hints and turn in the
person whose main hub of computers is
actually running this virus
maybe it isn't an april fool's job
anyway if you're a pc user watch out
your computer is going to be at risk on
april 1st and april 2nd and april 3rd
but i all in all i suggest you update
your antivirus software you disable auto
play and you use real caution to what
you download and what you actually click
on when you're on the internet for these
next couple weeks so um i hope you like
this video i hope it was informative
entertaining helpful whatever it needs
to be and thanks for watching this video
so um
peace